it's me Justin here to tell you teach
you something I'm gonna teach you one
thing at least and we'll see what that
is
all right cool so uh that was you know
you've probably I won't belabor you on
on background I started a lot of
companies the one that worked was twitch
also invested in a lot of companies kind
of seen all sorts of every side of the
market and that really informed this new
business that I started called atrium so
I came here I want to tell you about
atrium and I want to tell you about some
of the growth hacks that I used to get
us going because it's been about exactly
a year now
in June we celebrated atriums first
birthday June 12th I think so you can
wish me a happy birthday alright so why
did I start atrium well at first I was
very brain damaged from twitch and when
you start a consumer startup as many of
you probably will find out people don't
really want to pay you they don't want
to pay you very much but so when I was
thinking about what should I do next
what startup should I start I really
really wanted to do something where you
get paid and so there was one constant
in our entire Twitter journey which was
we always no matter what how we were
doing as a business the amount we paid
our attorneys always went up and that's
sadly true and so I was like that seems
like a very interesting business to do
at the same time I was a partner at YC I
felt like I'd stopped learning I stopped
leveling up and I wanted to build
something into a big industry where I
felt like I could continue to scale you
know cuz we grouped which it was about
170 people when Amazon acquired it I
want to build a big business something
bigger than that and I felt like the
legal market was something that would
support that
and then lastly I'd been an experienced
client as I like to say I was in
voluntary power-user of corporate legal
services and so I was like well I know
what people want and I feel like I can
deliver it and what did they want well
here the problems I faced with legal
really quickly pricing seemed like
playing Russian roulette when I would
open those legal bills sometimes there
was highly variable response time when I
was working on a very important thing
where you know was a like an M&A or
fundraising round the quality of service
was super high but often times when we
wanted to do something else that wasn't
as important it was you know we'd be
waiting for for a long time for response
the quality itself was very variable
oftentimes there were mistakes because
there's a lot done by hand and then
there's very little transparency into
the process like I didn't know what the
steps were for anything I wanted to do
like a fundraising round what what are
the steps from getting you know legal is
not the end State
I wanted to get money in the bank or I
want to sell my company I always wanted
to do something and League was just a
blocker and when there was no
transparency into what was happening I
was very frustrated so we decided to
solve that with a couple different
things strategies moving everything to
fix pricing so we have a incentive to
make things more efficient over time now
increasing role specialization so that
we can increase response response times
and and I kind of right-size all the
legal work were you building all this
technology to do stuff behind the scenes
to actually lower costs and then we
starting with startups that's you guys
in the room because that's what I know
and sorbs you know they might start
small but eventually if they become the
next Airbnb or uber they end up spending
you know a lot on legal and so you get
the good stuff you're the kind of growth
hacks when I started the company there
were a couple things that I did to
really kickstart the process and grow it
pretty quickly so today you know atrium
has done over five hundred million
dollars in primary financings for
clients we have over 240 clients here in
Silicon Valley and around the country
and you know I think we've done a pretty
good job we scale from a team of four
people to 80 people in in this last year
so done some things okay but we're there
still a lot to do you know all I see is
problems and and there's a long road
ahead of you one thing I should say
is no matter who you are it never gets
easier that's a lot of nervous laughter
but that that's actually true it's a so
so if you feel stressed out if you feel
like you're struggling with your startup
you know might be early days but you
should just you know know that I'm I'm
feeling the same pain somewhere in the
world probably in San Francisco I'm
probably banging my head against the
table on something that's not scaling
exactly right I thought it would be
easier actually this time so that was my
mistake all right on to the growth hacks
so the first one was when we started off
I was like will anyone hire a start-up
law firm and in fact lots of people were
like nobody will ever trust their
sensitive you know legal work to a you
know a new startup that's unproven and
so what we did was we ended up hiring
top talent and and trying to leverage
their credibility so first thing I did
was I realized you know couldn't start a
tremulous
who had a ton of experience and I ended
up yeah because I'm not I've been the
client site but I've never been on the
legal service providers side so we ended
up spending I spend a lot of time months
and months and months talking to
different partners seeing who was
interested in kind of innovating in this
space people who had been successful in
the careers at other firms and
eventually I decided to co-found atrium
with my current co-founder Augie Rico
who is a who was a partner at auric on
the you know emerging companies BC
practice and so all you had a great book
of business he was known as someone who
was very interested in kind of
innovating but also like really founder
of friendly and and like great at
building you know client development and
so we got along super well we end up
meeting because he he actually represent
my brother's company cruise automation
through their sale to GM for a billion
dollars the year before and so so we got
to it we sat down a lot got to know each
other and really put a lot of thought
pre work into building this business
together then after that all you know
you kind of broke the dam and we were
able to hire a bunch of talented
attorneys from top firms here in Silicon
Valley and so when we went to founders
we will say hey
we can offer the same levels of service
that you can expect from other firms and
you know I think that that was a huge
piece of the puzzle because we were
legitimately able to say hey if you are
going to go with this this other firm
you know we can do the same amount of
work but we promise we're gonna fix the
pricing and we're going to do it you're
gonna be you know we're gonna improve
our quality service we can improve up
our our response time we're going to
lower your cost because we have built
this technology that's going to
streamline the delivery service and it
worked
that was not obvious to me that it would
work at first but it did which is really
good so what was the second thing we did
we decided to try to help founders with
additional value outside of just the
legal services so in the very beginning
like literally a year ago we were
sitting around we're like how are we
going to get any clients and the way
that what I would have it started off
the whole thing by just posting on a
forum for founders actually was on the
internal YC forum and I said hey if you
are thinking about going through a
fundraising process soon for like a
series a financing series be financing
something like that I would love to get
customer feedback from you I just want
to learn about how your think about that
process and do some customer development
for my new company and in exchange what
I'll do is I will help you on your pitch
I'll give you some pitch feedback
because I've you know I've raised about
80 million dollars in fundraising from
venture capitalists and angel investors
and seed investors so far and I think I
have a lot of you know kind of firm
beliefs on how you improve the narrative
and your pitch narrative and I could
probably help you out so let's like
let's do a trade and so I did that with
one of my friends actually who has this
company called message bird which helps
helps people send you know it's
basically a chat like a SMS and phone
API and sat down with him he had a great
business business growing superfast or
they're on track to do I think 80
million dollars in revenue that year and
I sat down with him and and and he was
like I can't get any traction with
investors
what's going wrong and so helped him out
with his narrative and two weeks later
he had a term sheet and it raising 460
million bucks so it wasn't quite as
simple as that but you know I did really
help improve his his process and so you
you know then at that point when he had
the term sheet I was like hey you know
we have this law firm if you'd like to
maybe you know you could consider using
it and he was you know excitedly was
like yeah sure I'd love to give you guys
give give atrium a try and that's how we
kicked it off so we eventually did a
bunch of experiments over the summer
helping people out
and we decided to professionalize it we
said hey we can batch process this by
running a free bootcamp you know every
quarter I think we send it up being
every couple months and so that's what
we did we called it atrium scale and we
helped founders raise money and figure
out how what their fundraising strategy
is because it's effectively a lead-gen
event for our you know our atrium
services right so that's worked pretty
well in fact we've had over I think 60
founders go through our bootcamp over
the last six months and I think about a
quarter of them ended up raising you
know Series A or series B okay so growth
act number three atriums
Series A our own series a fund raising
so when we went out to start this
business we thought maybe I can
jump-start it by having all of our
investors or our future investors
because there weren't an investor's yet
maybe I can jump started by having all
of them basically become our channel
partners and so the way we created our
round was we ended up raising money from
one lead who set the terms I was General
Catalyst and then we ended up basically
well I guess we used our credibility and
hustle to get in the room and we turned
up talking to about a hundred and
vesser's total and I just pitched I was
like pitching non-stop like day after
day and got everyone participate with us
like a little amount you know a hundred
thousand or to five hundred thousand
it's just trying to raise like I was
kind of like a small amount from
everybody in Silicon Valley and the
reason I wanted to do that was twofold
number one I didn't want people
to block us just like I was worried
founders would be nervous that there was
a about having a new firm I thought
investors would be super nervous right
because investors you know what's the
point of like why I innovate here if
like the founders kind of the one that's
bearing the pain he should just like
suck it up and maybe use easy use their
you know existing firm that I've heard
about right I was worried about that so
I went out and I tried to pitch everyone
in Silicon Valley and then the second
reason that I thought that was that
would be useful is that we would be able
to ask them to refer us to their
portfolios and and really make those
investors believe that they could help
us grow and they they'd have like a
direct influence in helping us be more
successful and so we ended up doing that
and here's some of the results you know
I talked about that one atrium scale has
grown pretty well we've we've been able
to grow that from like this large base
of stars here in Silicon Valley we end
up raising rent around from almost
everybody in in Silicon Valley we had
participation from kind of all of these
different top-tier investors and they've
done a great job of referring us to this
you know portfolio over 240 clients who
have tried atrium today and in fact you
know there's 25 percent of those guys
come from from from our investors all
right so last up how I can help further
you can email us at atrium if you need
any sort of legal help an atrium scale I
encourage you all to apply if you're
thinking about raising venture fund
fundraising in the future it's been
pretty effective so far and I think
there's one last thing we have a special
discount for any of the founders in the
room today you just look for someone in
an atrium in an orange t-shirt and and
go find them to claim it so that's all
I've got for you today thank you very
much and I'll talk to you later bye
you